ومنذ اليوم الاول لم تكن فكره الروس صائبه
عندما اختاروا التقليل من قدرات القوات
الاوكرانيه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشفت ان
الجيش الروسي بدا يتعلم من اخطائه ويتكيف
مع تكتيكات القوات الاوكرانيه في ميدان
القتال الصحيفه اضافت ان القوات الروسيه
تحسنت على مستوى الانضباط والتنسيق والدعم
الجوي ما ينظر بحرب متغيره والدليل وفق
الصحيفه ان الروس نصبوا كمينا كان جزءا من
عمليه وصفت بالصبوره والمنضبطه كانت على
النقيض من التكتكه الروسيه التي وصفتها
بغير المنضبطه والتي ميزت الفتره السابقه
من الحرب مسؤولون غربيون اكدوا ان هذه
التحسينات ستجعل روسيا على الارجح خصما
اكثر صرامه وتلعب على نقاط قوتها في ساحه
المعركه
ياتي هذا في وقت اعترف وزير الدفاع الروسي
سرغو بان القوات الروسيه تعاني نقصا في
الدبابات وان زياده تصنيع الدبابات ضروريه
لتلبيه احتياجات القوات الروسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات